it is my privilege to present the Oscar
for the best performance by an actor lar
boost of its armor yummy now the winner
is
Gregory Peck
ladies and gentlemen miss Sofia Lauren
thank you very much
Gregory and every friend and every
colleague your generosity fills me with
happiness and great pride I remember my
first Oscar it was overwhelming for me
that the terror of having to face you
all made me find so many excuses not to
be with you 30 30 years ago tonight I'm
still scared but I'm not alone and I
will share this eventful evening with
the three men in my life
my husband Carlo Ponti without whom
without whom I wouldn't be the person I
am today and my two sons Carlo jr. and
they do our dough
that taught me to conjugate the verb to
love now a thousand feelings grab my
heart what I'm holding this wonderful
statue and words are very difficult to
find for me and to express it all in
this wonderful moment in my life so I
try to revert in my native language and
say simply gratia America